est-il possible que je connaisse une femme au
sens biblique c'est une histoire vraie à
propos d'un mec au poumon d'acier qui à la
mi-trentaine décide qu'il ne
veut plus être vierge il y a des gens
qu'on appelle les substituts sexuels hein
avec l'aide  de son thérapeute et des
conseils de son prêtre
parlons-nous de rapports sexuels
je pense donc en dehors du mariage mon pénis
me parle père Brendan il contacte
une mère porteuse malade salut Mark O'Brien qui est
en même temps comme une
maman de football régulière ton argent  sur le bureau là-bas
c'était vraiment on recommence et
l'histoire parle de son petit voyage vers la
virilité et de leur
relation fascinante allez-y hein allez-y
[Musique]
je commercialise un très bon sens de l'humour
il c'était important pour moi  dans le
film pour trouver que partout où nous pouvions mettre
fin à un sentiment de combat et comment vous
sentez-vous en ce moment, je voulais dire que vous respirez
bien mieux que d'habitude c'est génial
allons-nous nous déshabiller je pense que ce
personnage que je dois jouer fait salut  s est
entré et va Wow d'accord c'est un
corps vraiment difficile allons-y donc je pense qu'elle le
voit réellement, elle le
voit réellement et veut vraiment vraiment vraiment
veut le meilleur pour lui
a beaucoup crié quand j'ai enlevé sa chemise
mais je pense  plus par peur que par douleur, la
marque n'était pas paralysée, mais il n'avait aucun
mouvement ou quoi que ce soit sous son cou
autre que son pénis qui
semblait fonctionner correctement mm-hmm les signaux de votre
corps de cette façon vous pourrez avoir un
certain contrôle je  l'a fait à nouveau
une partie importante d'être un être humain est l'
amour et le sexe et il voulait savoir
qu'il était à la merci de quiconque le
touchait, il ne pouvait pas participer à
cela et je joue quelqu'un qui
enseigne avec acharnement  lui comment être
un avocat pour lui-même Je suis vraiment désolé
arrête d'être désolé et arrête de lire
ces manuels de sexe stupides c'est à propos de qui était le
vrai Mark O'Brien Je voulais vraiment que
toutes les personnes impliquées sentent que c'était aussi
proche que possible  l'expérience de Mark
pour commencer à peine à  pour espérer
penser à Mark comme un être humain et
non comme un il y a un gars
avec 90% de mouvement
vous savez de sa tête il est plus que ça
il
m'adore et je peux devenir assez pervers allez-y c'est
un film sur le dieu de tout le monde  -avoir le
droit d'avoir du plaisir et c'est moi est
rafraîchissant et excitant quel genre de
thérapie ils font en
ayant des relations sexuelles c'est un gars qui est né
avec une main crue qui en a tiré le meilleur
parti et il rencontre ces gens adorables
en cours de route et  ça te fait sourire
ouais peut-être que oui les oeufs l'amour est un voyage
j'aime déjà ça c'est tout
ce que j'ai
[Musique]